Football Leaks, infiltriert du Football Leaks.
Für uns ist super, dass wir hinter die Kulissen der Organisation FIFA sehen können und auseinandernehmen können, was sagen die öffentlich und was sagen sie hinter verschlossenen Türen und was entscheiden sie.
Da geht es wirklich um Milliarden, dass die zehn Top-Clubs in der Champions League pro Jahr praktisch eine Milliarde Euro erhalten und damit wird die Struktur in den nationalen Ligen, die wird, zerstört.
Der Fußball mag immer wieder propagieren, dass er für Fairness steht, dass er für bestimmte Werte steht. Wir sehen davon in den Dokumenten nichts.
Die Football Leaks, das einzige Thema im Rasenfunk, was sich so ein bisschen unserem Formaten verweigert. Ein Thema und jede Menge Nachspielzeit heißt es normalerweise im Tribünengespräch und normalerweise reden wir so lange über ein Thema, bis es zu Ende erzählt ist. Jetzt laufen die Football Leaks aber und deswegen müssen wir immer und immer wieder nachlegen. Und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch Nummer 27. Mein Name ist Max Hakob-Ost, ich bin der Gehnetzer bei Twitter und freue mich, dass wir jetzt schon zum vierten Mal diesen Themenkomplex hier behandeln können. Das heißt, wenn euch das Ganze ganz neu sein sollte oder ihr nochmal Lust habt, das von Anfang an nachzuhören, dann fangt doch an mit Kurzpass 35. Macht weiter mit Tribünengespräch Nummer 10, dann Tribünengespräch Nummer 20 und dann hört ihr hier die Nummer 27. Und ich freue mich, dass ich ihn wieder bei mir in der Leitung begrüßen kann. Rafael Buschmann vom Spiegel, Ed Raffanelli bei Twitter. Servus, Rafael. Es wird eine schöne Tradition, dass wir uns hier zu den Football Leaks treffen. Die Abstände werden auch immer kürzer, was vor allem mit eurem Veröffentlichungsrhythmus zu tun hat. Ich bin mal gespannt, wie lange wir das noch so weiterziehen können. Bis ins Jahr 2030, 2040, 2050. Was ist dein Gefühl?
Eine Sache würde ich gerne herausgreifen, weil du auch vorhin davon gesprochen hast, wie viel ihr abwägen müsst, um auch die Quelle, John und alles, was dahinter steht, zu schützen. Und da hätte ich eine Frage zu der Doku, die es gab im ersten. Das ist, wo man dich begleiten konnte, unter anderem, also es war ein Teil dieser Doku, aber auch übrigens der ja am meisten zitierte Teil, und auch auf dem Spiegel konnte man da Aussagen von dir sehen. Man konnte dir dabei zusehen, wie du dich mit John trist, und tatsächlich gab es dann auch ein Video, das John zeigt, vermummt und so weiter, aber man könnte zum Beispiel aus dem Video rauslesen, dass er Rechtshänder ist, weil er mit der rechten Hand die USB-Festplatte anschließt. Es gibt über Frequenzschwankungen in Stromnetzen, kann man manchmal über Videoaufnahmen auch einen Ort herausfinden. Ich habe mich gefragt, warum musste es sein, dass man dich auf dem Weg zu John sieht und dass man dann am Ende auch die Quelle selbst sieht? Welchen Mehrwert hat das, wenn er sich ja eh komplett vermummt und nicht spricht?
Ich habe das mit ziemlich vielen Bauchschmerzen gemacht. Ich habe das mit ihm im Vorfeld abgesprochen. Für den Film war es, ich bin kein Filmmacher, aber für den Film war es offenbar wichtig, einen roten Faden zu haben. Und der rote Faden war ich bzw. war John, der durch die sehr komplexen Geschichten führt. Das konnte ich ab einer gewissen Grenze oder einer gewissen Ebene nachvollziehen. Wir haben im Übrigen das gleiche Stilmittel für das Buch benutzt. Das Buch hat John als verbindendes Element zwischen den großen Enthüllungen. Das funktioniert sehr gut, weil man auf der einen Seite vielleicht komplexe Dinge erklären kann und gleichzeitig einen Krimi erzählen kann. Und so ist die Übertragung auf dem Film auf die Art und Weise auch stattgefunden. Ich selbst hätte es weder gebraucht, mich dort zu zeigen als Person, weil das auch mich gefährdet. Aber ich hätte es schon gar nicht gebraucht, ihn zu zeigen. Ich konnte aber nachvollziehen, dass die Regisseurinnen bzw. Regisseure, die den Film gemacht haben, auch für ihr Transparenzgefühl gesagt haben, wir müssen sehen, dass es noch eine zweite Person neben dir gibt. Und du am Ende nicht du derjenige bist, der dieses Zeug beschafft. Sondern dass es wirklich jemanden gibt, der das tut. Und du mit ihm in einem Raum bist. Auch das sind ja Elemente, die aus journalistischer Sicht für mich nachvollziehbar sind. Das war der Punkt, an dem sie mich auch bekommen haben. Weil wenn ich jetzt einsteigen würde in ein solches Projekt und einer erzählt mir, ja ja, ich habe da einen Whistleblower und der Whistleblower gibt uns irgendwelche Festplatten. Aber man selbst nie Zugang dazu hat, wäre ich sehr lange sehr skeptisch gewesen. Und so hatten auch die Filmemacher zumindest die Möglichkeit, in einer winzigen Sequenz zu sehen, da ist jemand, der uns diese Daten zur Verfügung stellt. Aber ansonsten wird von seiner Identität nichts preisgegeben. Das war ein Deal, den John auch nachvollziehen konnte.
Es ist eine interessante Debatte, auch weil es so ein Metathema ist, aber auch so ein bisschen eine Journalistendebatte. Ich verweise dazu auch nur auf einen Übermedienartikel, den ich verlinken werde in den Show Notes, rund um die Cum-Ex-Betrugsfälle gab es ein Panoramabeitrag. Die Überschrift ist ein bisschen anonym, wie Selfie, Journalismus, Informanten gefährdet. Das ist quasi die Metadebatte, die über so etwas steht. Wir haben ja auch schon häufiger darüber gesprochen. Der verantwortungsvolle Umgang mit Whistleblowern ist eines der wichtigsten Themen bei Football Leaks. Und in diesem Zusammenhang möchte ich mit dir auch noch über ein anderes Thema sprechen, nämlich einen Bericht eines portugiesischen Nachrichtenmagazins namens Sabado. Das glaubt zu wissen, wer Don sei, nämlich ein portugiesischer Student, der in Geschichte seinen Abschluss gemacht hat und später dann für ein Informatikstudium Portugal verlassen hat. Warum habe ich dazu im Spiegel und auf spiegel.de nichts gelesen?
Zum einen, weil es mich extrem befremdet, dass der gesamte Name einer Person irgendwo genannt wird, ohne dass diese Person sich dazu äußert, dass sie etwas dazu sagt.
Wobei er später dann mit Journalisten gesprochen hat. Das stimmt. Aber in der Ursprungsveröffentlichung wurde quasi nur über ihn berichtet und nicht mit ihm.
Das andere ist, ich glaube, das ist der achte Satz in dem Artikel, den ich auch gelesen habe, in dem steht, es gibt für all das keine Belege. Das steht drin, dass es offenbar ein Ermittlungsverfahren gegen eine Person gibt und dass diese Person möglicherweise etwas zu tun hat mit Football Leaks. Ich habe da keinerlei weitere oder fortführende Beweise zu gelesen oder Belege zu gelesen. Dementsprechend muss ich immer sagen, ich äußere mich nicht zu diesen Artikeln oder ich als Rechercheur werde nichts zu solchen Artikeln sagen. Weder kann ich sagen, ob er es ist, oder sagen, dass er es nicht ist, weil wenn ich damit anfange, komme ich ein totales Quellen-Bingo. Und wenn es dann irgendwann tatsächlich so sein sollte, dass da meine Quelle im Bild oder sonst was genannt wird und mich jemand fragt, dann kann ich mich eben nicht auf den Punkt zurückziehen, an den ich mich jetzt zurückziehen kann und sagen kann, dazu sage ich nichts. Aber dass du davon nichts im Spiegel gelesen hast, ist nicht richtig, weil in der Super League-Geschichte habe ich ein langes Kapitel über John, bei dem ich auf Medienberichterstattung, es war ja nicht nur Sabado, sondern es war die Medienberichterstattung in Portugal eingehe und dort eben beschreibe, dass es zahlreiche Vorwürfe gibt, mit denen ich John konfrontiere. Da geht es ja insbesondere um die Benfica-Lisabon-Berichterstattung, weil es dort in Portugal ein League gab, das nachweislich zeigt, dass Benfica-Lisabon, sagen wir es jetzt mal vorsichtig, aber in extreme Grenzbereiche der Legalität vorgeschlossen ist. Damit ist Korruption gemeint, damit ist Spielmanipulation gemeint, damit ist der nicht angemessene Umgang mit Schiedsrichtern gemeint. All das ist durch ein League in Portugal entstanden, was nicht als Football Leaks gelaufen, sondern ein Benfica League war. Und damit habe ich John konfrontiert. Er bestreitet, dass er derjenige war, der dieses League in Portugal ausgelöst hat. Er bestreitet nach wie vor, dass er ein Hacker ist. Er bestreitet, dass die Daten geklaut sind. Am Ende kann man das glauben oder man kann es sein lassen. Genauso schreibe ich es auch in dem und sage, wir können uns immer nur auf die rechtliche Position in Deutschland zurückziehen und sagen, weder haben wir jemanden gehackt, noch lassen wir irgendjemanden hacken, sondern wir sind diejenigen, die von einem Whistleblower Dokumente entgegennehmen, der sich als Whistleblower ausgibt, diese Dokumente oder der sich bezeichnet als Whistleblower. Wir können seinen Hintergrund nicht weitergehend prüfen. Offenbar kann es aber auch die Justiz nicht, denn sonst würde er nicht seit drei Jahren auf freiem Fuß sein. Wir können uns auf den Punkt zurückziehen, dass wir die Berichterstattung weiter fortführen können, weil wir mit Material arbeiten, das für die Öffentlichkeit relevant und authentisch ist. Dann ist der Ursprung, woher es kommt, für das deutsche Medienrecht uninteressant.
Das haben wir auch schon länger diskutiert. Die Diskussion hatten wir schon. Das stimmt natürlich, du hast es in dem aktuellen Aufmacher-Artikel gesagt. Mir ist aufgefallen, dass es damals, Mitte September, in der Süddeutschen ein größeres Stück dazu gab. Ansonsten habe ich im deutschsprachigen Journalismus fast nichts gefunden. Es war für mich fast unmöglich, jetzt noch mal alle Sachen nachzurecherchieren. Interessanterweise haben die UK-Kollegen an der Stelle wieder viel genauer. Die haben dann auch Pinto ausfindig gemacht, gibt da ein gutes Stück bei der Daily Mail. Das werde ich verlinken. Rui Pinto ist ein interessanter Fall. Da gibt es verschiedene Indizien, die darauf hinweisen, dass es da zumindest einen Bezug zu Football Leaks-Dingen gibt, unter anderem über einen Anwalt, der auch in Football Leaks-Dingen zu sprechen kommt. Ich will aber eigentlich bei dieser Jagd nach John gar nicht mitmachen, denn das finde ich persönlich ehrlich gesagt wenig relevant für die Öffentlichkeit, außer dass natürlich wir alle uns ein Interview von ihm angucken würden. Das ist halt der Edward Snowden-Effekt. Edward Snowden war toll dann zu sehen, wer dahinter steckt, warum er das gemacht hat und so weiter und so fort. Aber für die Debatte hat das eigentlich nichts zu tun. Deswegen will ich damit nichts mitmachen. Aber ich finde, da hängt ein zweiter Themenkomplex dran. Und das ist die Frage, auf die er auch immer wieder eingeht. Wie sauber ist Football Leaks? Aus welchen Quellen kommen diese Dinge? Wenn wir Chatverläufe haben, wenn wir zum Beispiel sehen, dass diese Europa League-Geschichte, Super Europa League, also die ESL-Geschichte, immer noch unfassbar, dass die sich so nennen wollen wie die ESL. Aber gut, ist halt der Fußball eher so arrogant zu glauben, dass er mit E-Sports nichts zu tun haben muss. Wahnsinn. Aber die war ja hochaktuell, unter anderem deshalb, weil es eine abgefangene E-Mail gab oder eine irgendwie entdeckte E-Mail, die im November 2018 zu einer Absichtserklärung führen hätte können oder vielleicht auch noch führen wird, wo sich eben dann die Vereine darauf verständigt hätten, wir machen das ganz konkret. Das war ja das, was so richtig der Zunder auf dieser Geschichte war, dass das nicht nur irgendwelche Gedankenspiele waren, sondern dass es eben diese E-Mail gab. Und wenn ich mir dann aber angucke, welche Quellen alle zur Verfügung liegen, da haben wir eben E-Mails, wir haben aber auch Chat-Verläufe, wir haben SMS-Verläufe. Ich finde, das ist etwas, über das Football Leaks immer angreifbar sein wird, dass man sagen kann, wie ist es da dran gekommen? Und dann ist auch eine Aussage, wir hacken nicht. Ich hoffe, du hast mal die Gegenfrage gestellt, aber habt ihr denn mal ein Passwort abgefangen oder etwas Ähnliches? Also beim DFB waren wohl offenbar, gab es einen, wie auch immer gearteten Angriff im August. Die FIFA wurde gehackt und dann ist die Frage, ob jemand ein Hacker ist, so ein bisschen auch eine Definitionssache. Hacker ist jemand, der Sicherheitssystem umgeht, um reinzukommen. Ist jemand, der zum Beispiel am Telefon sagt, hallo, ich bin die IT, gib mir mal kurz dein Passwort, ich muss da was ändern, der dann reinkommt, ist der noch ein Hacker?
Also klar, die Frage habe ich selbstverständlich gestellt. Auf die Frage habe ich genau die gleiche Antwort bekommen. John verweist immer wieder auf die Plattform WikiLeaks, bei der es Dutzende Dokumente gab und nie die Frage gestellt wurde, wie die Herkunft der Dokumente ist. Also nie, es ist nie Julian Assange vorgeworfen worden, dass er hacken würde. Man kann das glauben, man kann das lassen. Wir mit unseren Möglichkeiten haben, wir können das nicht ausfindig machen. Wir können uns die Dokumente ansehen. Wir können sehen, dass die Dokumente nicht fremdgesteuert sind. Also dass es nicht ein Angriff auf Real Madrid ist oder ein Angriff auf Bayern München oder ein Angriff auf den DFB, sondern dass nahezu jeder aus der Fußballbranche irgendwie eine Rolle in diesen Dokumenten spielt. Wir haben keine Data und Metadaten dieser Dokumente, die wir sehen könnten, woher sie am Ende tatsächlich stammen. Wir haben die Docs und können die Plausibilität der Docs checken. Und da war es halt durchweg so, dass die Plausibilität für uns niemals Anlass gegeben hat, um einen Zweifel an den Dokumenten herzustellen. Und dass diese Debatte geführt wird, das müssen wir im Prinzip dann auch hinnehmen und diese Debatte auch so führen lassen. Es bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig. Irgendwann wird man sehen, wie der Hintergrund dieser Dokumente ist. Wir können als Journalisten ja immer wieder nur sagen, wir befinden uns auf rechtlich einwandfreien Boden, in dem wir mit diesen Dokumenten arbeiten. Wenn du diese Frage überträgst auf die Frage, wo beispielsweise die Panama Papers herkommen oder die Paradise Papers herkommen oder Offshore Leaks herkommen, das ist eine ganz wichtige Enthüllung der letzten Jahre, wirst du ja diese Debatte immer wieder auch führen. Du wirst immer wieder an die Frage kommen, wie kann es sein, dass solche Datenberge am Ende irgendwie bei Journalisten aufschlagen.
Aber warum wird es denn hier bei den Football Leaks diese Debatte so sehr anders geführt, als eben zum Beispiel bei den Panama Papers? Liegt es vielleicht daran, weil ihr euch dazu entschieden habt, mit John eine Figur aufzumachen, die es ja gibt, aber die ja stellvertretend zu sein scheint, zumindest für ein größeres Netzwerk?
Da spricht man nicht darüber. Ich kann am Ende sogar noch sagen, ich habe einen leibhaftigen Menschen kennengelernt und konnte mit ihm reden, konnte mit ihm diskutieren, konnte prüfen, wie seine Geisteshaltung zu all den Dingen ist und ob er verlässlich ist in dem, wie er sich verhält oder nicht.
Aber woran liegt es denn dann, dass wir hier bei den Football Leaks so viel über solche Themen diskutieren, die ich damit nicht marginalisieren will, aber es stimmt ja, wenn du sagst, wir führen hier eine Diskussion, die bei anderen Vergleichbarenfällen nicht geführt wird.
Möglicherweise ist es, also man muss ja die Frage stellen, von wem wird sie geführt. Sie wird natürlich in erster Linie von Medien geführt. Wenn die Süddeutsche Zeitung den Sabado-Artikel aufnimmt und ihn in der Größenordnung zeigt, aber dort ebenfalls den Satz zitiert, dass es für all das keine Belege gibt und dass man all das nicht beweisen kann, dann bin ich ehrlicherweise auch ein bisschen erschrocken über die Qualität, mit der wir uns mit solchen Themen beschäftigen. Gerade die Süddeutsche Zeitung, die sich dann auch hinstellt und sagt, wir versuchen, einen maximalen Quellenschutz zu garantieren und wir sind das Haus, das mit den Leaks gearbeitet hat. Und dann aber diese Debatte genau in diese Richtung führt, jetzt noch mal unabhängig davon, ob es die Quelle ist oder nicht, was ja eigentlich noch viel schlimmer ist. Auch nach dem Artikel, den man noch nicht weiß. Ich finde das grenzwertig, ich finde das schwierig. Es ist eine Diskussion, die mich aber auch nicht umtreibt, weil ich mich mit der Person des Whistleblowers nur soweit beschäftige, soweit ich das mit mir selbst vereinbaren kann und soweit ich das auch mit John besprechen kann. Ich habe immer gesagt, dass ich das über John schreibe, worüber ich mit ihm im Vorfeld auch spreche und ihm sage, dass ich finde, dass das und das wichtig ist, dass das veröffentlicht werden sollte und das dann auch tue, wenn er sagt, das ist in Ordnung. Das ist für mich eine Form des Quellenschutzes, die ich nicht in jedem Alltag machen würde. Aber hier versuche ich, maximal natürlich eine Person zu schützen, die jetzt über Jahre immense Risiken auf sich nimmt. Davon nichts im Prinzip privat hat, sondern einfach möchte, dass eine Branche, die aus seiner Sicht echte Probleme hat, wieder sauberer wird. Und dass die Person versuche ich zu schützen, so gut es geht.
Okay, lass uns noch kurz am Schluss, weil wir haben ja auch schon gelernt, deine Zeit ist natürlich sehr beschränkt, sogar für den Rasenfunk. Zwei Themen würde ich gerne kurz noch mit dir besprechen. Zum einen noch mal zurückkommen zu Gianni Infantino und seinen Bezug zu Geld. Wir haben jetzt über seine Zeit als UEFA-Generalsekretär gesprochen und in seiner Stellungnahme hatte er auch unter anderem diesen wunderbaren Satz gesagt, dass alles Dinge, die nichts mit der FIFA zu tun haben. Warum nerven Sie mich damit? Ich bin ja jetzt FIFA-Präsident. Okay, nehmen wir ihn beim Wort und gucken, was er als FIFA-Präsident gemacht hat. Auch da war Geld das wichtigste Thema für ihn, denn er hat den Verbänden der FIFA, die ihn zum Präsidenten gewählt haben, viel davon versprochen. Allein 1,4 Milliarden US-Dollar bei seiner Wahl zum Präsidenten. Da gab es dann noch so eine kleine Nebengeschichte. Ganz interessant, weil die FIFA-Verwaltung aber genauer hingeschaut hat und mehr Fragen bei der Verteilung stellte, kam bei vielen Verbänden fast gar nichts an. Und erst 2017 wurden da die Schleusen geöffnet und seitdem wird das Geld offenbar, nachdem was man jetzt dann bei euch nachlesen konnte, wieder, ich sage mal, mit offenen Händen verteilt und dabei die Augen geschlossen. Wer auf der einen Seite aber viel Geld ausgibt, der muss ja auf der anderen Seite neue Einkünfte haben. Und hier kommt jetzt das Projekt Trophy mit ins Spiel. Kannst du uns kurz sagen, worum geht es dabei? Und vor allem interessiert mich die Frage, kann das Konsequenzen für Gianni Infantino haben, was ihr da aufdecken konntet?
Oder organisiert werden soll, der der FIFA 25 Milliarden Einkommen verspricht. Wenn wir uns auf der einen Seite mit der Super League beschäftigen und mit den Ideen einer Gründung der Super League, dann beschäftigt man sich auf der anderen Seite natürlich damit, wie Gianni Infantino versucht, die Macht über die Clubs zurückzuerlangen. Und zwar weggehend von der UEFA, indem er ihnen eine Weltliga offeriert, mit der sie extrem viel Geld, also 150 Millionen plus pro Verein, für eine Art Sommerturnier einnehmen können. Und dadurch versucht natürlich, diese Vereine auch in den großen Verbänden zu behalten. Gianni Infantino, wenn wir uns die Berichterstattung ansehen, auch sein Eingreifen in den Ethicode, bei dem er den Begriff Korruption ausradiert hat, ich fand die Aussagen vom ehemaligen, oder vom Richter Eckart dazu sehr humorig, der gesagt hat, Gianni Infantino ist mit den Worten angetreten, Korruption aus der Vielfalt zu entfernen. Das hat er geschafft, das Wort taucht dem Ethicode nicht mehr auf. Er hat es radiert. Man kann sehen, wie er mit Mitarbeitern, also aus den Dokumenten kann man sehen, wie er mit Mitarbeitern umgeht, wie er Mitarbeiter auch als Handpuppen benutzt, wie er seine Machtposition stärkt, indem er Mitarbeiter dazu bringt, diese Gelder aus den Sozialpaketen zu verteilen. Das ist ja nichts anderes als das, was Joseph Blatter früher gemacht hat mit Geldverteilungen, um seine eigene Macht zu zementieren. Nur eben diesmal zumindest unter dem Deckmantel der Öffentlichkeit, wobei wir sehen ja, dass die Geldflüsse auch abseits der internationalen Gesetze und Regularien ablaufen, um bestimmte Gelder in bestimmte Länder zu bringen und diese Länder dann weiterhin auch mit Gianni Infantino sympathisieren zu lassen, weil sie eben von der FIFA profitieren. Im Gegenteil ist es so, dass man bei Gianni Infantino sehen kann, und zwar beginnt mit den, wenn ich da den Kant machen kann, beginnt mit den Einmischungen in das Financial Fair Play bis eben heute zum Eingreifen in den Ethic Code, zum Umgang mit den Mitarbeitern, zu seinen völlig intransparenten Ideen des Project Trophies. Im Übrigen sollte der Trust in einer Steueroase in Jersey aufgelegt werden, das also nur zu seiner Transparenz und zu seinem Fingerspitzengefühl gegenüber den aktuellen Debatten. Man muss am Ende sagen, dass dieser Mensch nach all dem, was wir gelesen haben, charakterlich und von der Persönlichkeit her vollkommen fehl am Platz ist, an der Stelle als führende Person eines Verbandes, der nicht nur rechtliche, sondern auch moralische und ethische Ebenen dieses Sportes erfüllen soll und als Instanz für alle anderen stehen soll. Das bildet Gianni Infantino aus unserer Sicht an keiner Stelle ab. Ganz im Gegenteil, er ist im Prinzip das Fleisch von Fleisch in der Lage, all die Deals, die im Fußball ablaufen, auf genau die Art und Weise mitzugehen, auch um seine eigene Machtposition nach wie vor zu stellen.
Und dann kommt man, das scheint einen noch weniger zu überraschen, ein bisschen hat man da eben auch ein Zapplatter-Dijavu und das führt dann eben jenseits von dieser einen Person zu der Frage, was für Veränderungen müssten denn eigentlich her, dass man verhindern kann, dass ein Präsident dem so etwas nachgewiesen werden kann. Offenbar ja mit sehr glaubwürdigen Quellen und so wirklich richtig hat er sich dagegen auch nicht gewehrt. Es ist interessant, welche Argumentationsstrategie er da erfährt. Wie kann man sich dagegen eigentlich als Verband wehren? Was gibt es da sowohl für juristische Möglichkeiten als auch eben wie könnte jetzt zum Beispiel der DFB, der ja auch in bestimmten Gremien mitsitzt, da agieren und das ist jetzt losgelöst von der Person Infantino, die man mögen kann, aber nicht mögen muss und wahrscheinlich weniger mag nach diesen Veröffentlichungen ja die eigentliche Frage.
Also zunächst einmal zum Dementieren. Ich habe sowohl von Gianni Infantino als auch von Karl-Heinz Rummenigge gelernt, dass es sehr einfach ist im Fußball etwas zu dementieren. Und zwar man dementiert einfach etwas, was einem gar nicht vorgeworfen wurde. Und dadurch hat man ein Statement, das um die ganze Welt geht. Das ist eine sehr einfache Möglichkeit, vielleicht auch so ein bisschen die Stimmung oder das Bild rund um eine Enthüllung zu negieren.
Ihr müsstet halt einfach in Zukunft in Instagram-Stories eure Enthüllungen machen über irgendwelche Spielerfrauen-Accounts. Und dann wird das unwidersprochen einfach so zitiert. Und dann könnt ihr nämlich die genaue Wortwahl diktieren.
Aber auch das ist Wahnsinn. Also wenn wir über Standards reden und über die Möglichkeiten, wie Journalismus eigentlich abbildet, ist das natürlich etwas, woran aber auch schon ganz andere Rechercheure wie Jens Weinreich oft in den letzten Jahren verzweifelt sind und das Gefühl hatten, hier hat man harte Dokumente, man kann etwas offenlegen und auf der anderen Seite sagt einfach etwas und es geht über alle Agenturen in die ganze Welt. Und man fragt sich, warum zur Hölle durfte der das denn jetzt sagen? Das hat ihm niemand vorgeworfen.
Beziehungsweise, warum wurde es nicht in Kontext gesetzt? Es ist ja völlig richtig journalistischer Grundsatz, alle Seiten zu Wort kommen zu lassen, aber den Kontext kann man ja liefern.
Das ist das eine. Das andere ist, dass selbstverständlich jetzt eigentlich Ermittlungen gegen Gianni Infantino und gegen sein Eingreifen sowohl in den Ethikkodex als auch in die Settlements rund um das Financial Fair Play als auch in die Einsetzung von Frau Rojas eigentlich stattfinden müssten. Reinhard Grinde als Mitglied des UEFA Exkurs hat ja schon angekündigt, dass die UEFA sich mit den Machenschaften von Herrn Infantino beschäftigen will und wird. Ich persönlich bin da sehr skeptisch, ob dabei irgendetwas Ernsthaftes rumkommen wird. Das sind ja nicht Untersuchungsausschüsse, wie man sie im Bundestag kennt oder im EU-Parlament, wo jemand dann auch wirklich gegrillt wird und Dokumente vorgehalten werden, sondern das wird in deutlich geringerem Umfang und Zirkeln versucht zu erraten. Da muss man dann mal sehen, ob wirklich etwas dabei rumkommt. Der Fußball lebt ja davon, dass es an jeder Stelle einen Interessenskonflikt gibt, dass keiner den anderen so wirklich angreifen möchte. Das ist Gianni Infantinos Nähe zu Karlheinz Rummenigge ist bekannt, seine Nähe zu Eva, wo er herkommt, ist relativ klar, auch wenn Herr Schäferin sich im Moment ein bisschen gegen ihn positioniert. Aber auch da erwarte ich eigentlich nicht, dass es zu einem klaren Bruch kommt. Die Europäer haben Infantino in seine Machtposition gebracht. Das heißt, sie werden nicht diejenigen sein, die ihn jetzt dort mit aller Macht wieder wegkegeln. All diese Punkte sind ja ganz entscheidend dafür, dass es schwierig ist, dass externe Untersuchungen aus dem Fußball heraus Gianni Infantino wirklich in Bedrängnis bringen. Und die internen Untersuchungsmöglichkeiten, die hat er ja durch die Abschaffung von Bobbily und von Eckart, also durch die Abschaffung der Ethikkammer und der rechtsprechenden Kammer, im Prinzip ausgehebelt. Er hat mit Frau Rochas jetzt jemanden installiert. Das haben wir ja in epischer Breite versucht zu beschreiben, wie machtlos diese Frau eigentlich ist, die auch der Sprachen nicht mächtig ist, deren Englisch nicht gut genug ist, die Komfranzösisch sprechen kann, die aber genau in diesen Verkehrssprachen in der Lage sein soll, Urteile zu entwickeln oder bzw. Anklagen zu entwickeln. Das ist nahezu ausgeschlossen, dass so etwas funktioniert. Fatma Zamora als Generalsekretärin ist auch nicht die starke Person, die Gianni Infantino wirklich dort auch nochmal zur Rede stellen würde und sagen würde, das müssen wir jetzt aufklären, damit müssen wir uns jetzt beschäftigen. Der Fußball hat es ja noch nicht mal geschafft, von Gianni Infantino tatsächlich die Aussagen zu bekommen, wer hinter diesem Project Trophy als Geldgeber steht. Selbst das ist ja am Ende, der hat es sich einfach verweigert. Der hat dieses Angebot in die Gesprächsrunde reingeworfen und hält daran ja fest und lässt es ja immer wieder in den Zirkeln der UEFA diskutieren. Aber er hat bis heute nicht offen gelegt, nicht transparent offen gelegt, wer sind die Geldgeber dahinter? Wer sind diejenigen, die tatsächlich einen solchen Trust aufbauen wollen?
Ja, der sollte sowieso inzwischen mehr als schüttert sein. Lass uns noch über ein Thema kurz sprechen, nämlich den man finde, man kann tatsächlich sagen, den Kinderhandel mit Fußballspielenden Jugendlichen. Da haben wir nämlich unter anderem auch in einer Doku, die jetzt kürzlich lief, gelernt. Da hat Manchester City mal wieder in unrühmlicher Art und Weise seine Hände mit im Spiel. Aber wir können auch hier in Deutschland über einige Fälle zumindest reden. Kurz, was hat Manchester City gemacht? Seit 2010 investiert man jährlich mit mehr als einer Million Euro in eine Fußballschule in Ghana. Und das Wort Investment ist hier auch richtig, denn das wird von City selbst in internen Papieren als Venture Capital, also eben als Kapitalanlage bezeichnet. Denn man hat zuerst Zugriff auf diese Spieler, sobald die 18 Jahre alt werden, kann man sie zu Manchester City holen, wenn sie denn den entsprechenden Qualitätsstandard erfüllen. Oder eben, man kann sie zu anderen Mannschaften verleihen. Und da gibt es dann eine Dreiecksvereinbarung mit dem dänischen FC Nordjelland. Spieler gehen dorthin, dürfen dann nur mit Genehmigung von City weiterverkauft werden. Und wenn sie gut genug sind, wechseln sie kostenlos zu City. Und das, was Nordjelland davon hat, ist ein Teil der Ablösesumme. Jetzt muss man dazu kurz den rechtlichen Rahmen wieder erklären. Man darf nicht mit Jugendlichen, die Fußball spielen, Geld verdienen, bis diese vorjährig sind. Und jetzt haben wir hier, im Fall von Manchester City und gleich noch einem anderen, den ich dann gleich noch erzählen werde, ein jetzt dokumentierter Fall, wo diese juristische Vorgabe ausgehebelt wird. Was kann jetzt dagegen getan werden?
Also ich finde es erstmal wahnsinnig schade, dass wir nicht mehr wirklich viel Zeit haben, um dieses Thema näher auszusprechen.
Ich auch.
Ich bin gleich in dem nächsten Termin. Wenn dieses Thema die Zuhörer des Rasenfunks interessiert und dich auch interessiert, dann empfehle ich euch dafür auch nochmal Christoph Winterbach zu befragen, denn er war derjenige, der dieses Thema federführend für uns recherchiert hat und der dazu sehr viel zu sagen hat. Ich selbst habe auch in den letzten Jahren sehr viel über den Kinderhandel im Fußball geschrieben und habe über Fälle geschrieben, bei denen ich gesehen habe, wie insbesondere afrikanische Nachwuchsfußballer, wie Handelsware von einem Ort zum anderen geschickt wurden. Über das System, das wir jetzt im aktuellen Spiegel beschreiben und auch das, was der NDR in seiner Dokumentation gezeigt hat, diese Dreiecksbeziehung mit Manchester City, muss ich persönlich sagen, hat mich selten so dermaßen angefasst, weil man dort schlicht und ergreifend wirklich sehen kann, dass der Zionismus im Fußball kaum Grenzen kennt. Weil man dann sieht, dass solche jungen Fußballer in der Masse, in der Häufigkeit, in der Größenordnung aus Afrika hier hingeholt werden, nach Europa geholt werden, hier in Europa dann auch nochmal weiter verschickt werden.
Zum Teil gegen ihren Willen offenbar?
Und sie es selbst heute sogar noch bestätigen und sagen, wir wollten das nicht. Und Fußballer, die jetzt sagen, jetzt sind wir frei, wir sind weg aus den Verträgen und sind jetzt frei, nachdem das funktioniert hat. Andere junge Fußballer in Afrika, die vor der Kamera sagen, ich vermisse meine Eltern, ich vermisse meine Familie, die aber als Investment und als Kapitalanlage von europäischen Clubs benutzt werden. All das sind Dinge, über die wir normalerweise das nächste Tribünengespräch machen müssten, auch in der Länge, weil das etwas ist, was, wenn man sich den Fußball jetzt in unterschiedlichen Ebenen anguckt, wir haben lange darüber gesprochen, wie systemkaputt die Verbände sind, wie problematisch der Umgang der Vereine mit den Verbänden und auch untereinander ist, wie extrem das Kapital über ethische, moralische und gesetzliche Ebenen im Sport steht. Dann kommen wir irgendwann natürlich an die unterste Grenze, und die unterste Grenze ist eben dann der Nachwuchsbereich und der Nachwuchshandel. Wir haben ja im Spiegel auch eine lange Geschichte über Pinyas Sahavi, der als einer der erfolgreichsten Berater der Welt agiert und der auf die gleiche Art und Weise mit Jugendspielern hantiert und dort Jugendspieler transferrechte erwirbt über Firmen, die dann verteilt werden und diese Spieler in dieser Abhängigkeit, diese Firma gelagert werden. Also all das, ich mache jetzt einen sehr, sehr schnellen Überflug, aber all das müsste man jetzt normalerweise noch lange ausdiskutieren. Dieses Thema ist ja eines der zentralen Themen, wenn wir uns dazu Gedanken machen, wie durchsetzt der Fußball mit so fehlerhaften Entwicklungen ist. Und da betrifft er diejenigen, die sich nahezu nicht wehren können, und zwar Kinder.
Genau, absolut. Und weißt du, was genau das werden wir tun? Ich werde nicht nur Christoph, sondern auch noch ein paar anderen da einige Mails schicken. Das muss im Rasenfunk nochmal stattfinden. Ich kann an der Stelle nur nochmal sehr auch die Doku empfehlen, die es da im Sportclub gab. Am 11. November wurde die ausgestrahlt von Katrin Kampling und Nino Seidel. Wird noch eine Weile in der Mediathek verfügbar sein. Und vielleicht ja auch noch länger bei YouTube. Es wird definitiv verlinkt werden. Und wir werden dieses Thema noch hier abhandeln und dann auch aufklären, was haben da eigentlich Kai Havertz mit zu tun. Oder andere Spieler auch, die zum Beispiel bei Borussia Dortmund dann mal waren, oder die hingewechselt sind zu Rasenball Sport Leipzig. Das muss jetzt als Teaser genügen. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, schaut euch die Doku an. Und wir müssen, auch wenn das manchmal wehtut, denn manche Szenen dieser Doku sind auch wirklich nicht leicht zu ertragen, wenn da 10-jährige Kinder erzählen, dass sie doch ihre Mama schon sehr vermissen. Und wir dann wissen, wie ihre Perspektive ist. Es ist kein schönes Thema, aber wir müssen manchmal auch dahin gucken. Und man kann ja danach dann wieder mit Netflix sein Hirn wieder reinwaschen von solchen schlechten Einflüssen. Rafael, ich danke dir sehr, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast, trotz deines sehr vollen Terminkellen. Ja, und natürlich auch an die Zuhörerinnen. Ich freue mich wieder auf die Diskussion, die es sicher auch wieder dazugeben wird. Auf mitmachen.rasen.de At rafanelli heißt Rafael bei Twitter und er antwortet da auch gerne auf Fragen. Wir haben ja auch gehört, dass alles ist ein wichtiger Teil dieser Football Leaks Enthüllung. Euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, herzlichen Dank vor allem allen Supporterinnen und Supportern. Ich habe sehr viel Zeit in die Vorbereitung hier gesteckt. Warum konnte ich das tun? Weil ihr mich finanziert. Herzlichen Dank dafür. Macht's gut.
Danke.